Some psychologists have suggested the Frustration Aggression Hypothesis. And
this hypothesis states that we're likely to experience aggression when we're
frustrated from not being able to meet our goals. Here's a simple example. A
dog sees a piece of meat fall on the ground. That's his goal. A cat comes along
and is also tempted to get that piece of meat. That is the frustration, and
then the dog attacks the cat. That would be the aggression. Although this
explains some of our behavior, psychologists have suggested that the
frustration we experience from not being able to meet our goals is what results
in aggression. And interestingly we see this aggression in other animals. For
example, if rats are shocked in a laboratory, they will attack just about
anything in their cage, including another animal, a stuffed doll, or even a
tennis ball. But let's go to Grey to look at another type of aggression.